in this video of Yosemite high yield
series we will talk about stroke or
cerebrovascular accidents disruption of
cerebral blood flow leads to death of
brain cells resulting in acute onset
focal neurologic deficits this is known
as stroke this can be ischemic or
hemorrhagic now risk factors include
modifiable factors like hypertension
carotid stenosis diabetes mellitus
obesity hyperlipidemia
coronary artery disease atrial
fibrillation drugs like cocaine
non-modifiable factors include family
history of Mi stroke male gender age
more than 60 years or ethnicity like
African Americans Hispanics and Asians
are more prone to develop stroke
etiology includes hypertension hyper
cholesterolemia diabetes which lead to
Latino infarcts
atherosclerosis of extracranial or
intracranial vessels will lead to each
chemic
brain stroke and cardiac anaotic emboli
also cause stroke
symptomatology will include motor
symptoms like acute onset of weakness or
paralysis sensory symptoms like lack of
sensation or no sensation at all that is
hypostasia or anesthesia autonomic
symptoms will include autonomic
dysregulation like loss of bladder bowel
control and reflexes will be like
hyperreflexia that is diminished
reflexes or hyperreflexia that is
increased or brisk reflexes now based on
the area of the brain involved and the
vasculature involved there can be
anterior cerebral artery or ACA syndrome
middle cerebral artery or MCA syndrome
or posterior cerebral artery or PCS
syndrome we will talk about these in
later videos now how we diagnose stroke
we perform a non-contrast CT scan of
brain which helps us to distinguish
between ischemic and hemorrhagic stroke
then we perform blood tests like
coagulation studies and routine blood
cardiac enzymes and troponin to make a
etiological diagnosis once we have
diagnosed we treat ischemic stroke by
thrombolysis which is injecting drug to
dissolve blood clots and restoring blood
flow to the brain and hemorrhagic
Strokes are controlled or managed by
doing craniotomy and removal of clot by
surgical methods and prevention of
rebleed by controlling pressure
and maintaining the blood pressure now I
hope you have got a overview of Strokes
now if you want to get notes and flash
cards you can follow us on our Facebook
and Instagram page and you can support
our Channel by using the super thanks
icon present on the bottom right corner
of any video or you can support us on
our patreon page you can follow arpan
using the links given in the description
box below and for medicine related
content you can go and follow nerd medic
until then bye bye see you in the next
one